good morning everyone and welcome to the
Royal Swedish Academy of Sciences and
this press conference the Academy has
concluded its meeting and we are ready
to announce this year's Nobel Prize in
Physics and as usual we'll do it both in
Swedish and in English hi I'm Joanne
Hansen and the secretary-general of the
Academy to my right is Professor Nils
motors on the acting chairman of the
Nobel Committee for physics to my left
professor - Shaun Johnson who is not a
brother of mine but a member of the
committee and an expert in the field of
the prize later on we hope to have one
of our new Nobel laureates with us on
the phone this year's Nobel Prize is
about exotic matter in the quantum world
or its Nobel Prize handler omics otis
materia accont Verdun come Leviathan
scopes Academy nobis lute attitude illa
sugar hundra Sexton ocean Bell please if
you seek me Anna Helton till David J
Paulus or Unruh health them till f
Duncan Holden oak J Michael coastal it's
for Theoretical protector of topological
forces were going on at Opel log is got
material for sir
the Royal Swedish Academy of Sciences
has decided to award the 2016 Nobel
Prize in Physics with 1/2 - David J
Fowler's and the other half - F Duncan
holding and J Michael Kosta leads for
theoretical discoveries of topological
phase transitions and topological phases
of matter future edition
cumin topological phase and I began a
'unto Pelagia material Azam bubbler
découverte week de transitioned faster
pelagic atoll pelagic de lama chair
zotti ret Chesky at creature topologies
kiss fans of each period of heat
apologies Kings Pass materi you have our
new Nobel laureates and the pictures on
the screen above me some personal
information de DJ Paulus was born in
beer stone in the United Kingdom in 1934
he is now emeritus professor at the
University of Washington in Seattle in
the United States
duncan whole day was born in london in
1951 he is the eugene higgins professor
of physics at Princeton University New
Jersey United States and J Michael Costa
leads was born in Aberdeen in the United
Kingdom in 1942 and he's currently
Harrison Ford's worth professor of
physics at Brown University Rhode Island
USA so that's the announcement and now
professor Niels Mortensen the acting
chairman of the Nobel Committee will
provide some introductory remarks on the
Nobel Prize in Physics Niels please yeah
this year's Nobel Prize recognizes
important discoveries in the field of
condensed matter physics and today's
advanced technology take for instance
our computers rely on our ability to
understand and control the properties of
the matters materials involved in this
year's Nobel laureates having their
theoretical work discovered a set of
totally unexpected regularities in the
behavior of matter which can be
described in terms of an established
mathematical concept namely that of
topology
this has paved the way for designing new
materials with novel properties and
there is great hope that this will be
important for many future technologies
Thank You nails and now professor to
Shan Shan Shan will give us some
insights into the discoveries that led
to the Nobel Prize hold please
so I am very happy to be here and to
tell you about this very deep and
actually very beautiful work that is at
the basis for this year's price and I
will start by explaining to you a
concept of the citation that might not
be familiar to you and that's the
concept of topology so I brought my
lunch and here you see it's a cinnamon
bun yeah here I have another thing I
have a bagel ok and here I have a
pretzel
- Swedish pretzel with two holes in it
now for us you know these things are
very different this is sweet this is
perhaps all the different shapes etc but
if you are a topologist you're it
apologies
is only one thing that is really
interesting with these things in which
they differ this thing has no hole
the bagel has one hold the pretzel has
two holes the number of holes is what
the topologists would call a topological
invariant and just as you cannot have a
half a hole or two and 2/3 holes you can
for a topological invariant only have
integer numbers okay only in digits and
another thing which is very important
for the following with topological
invariants is that it takes something to
change the topological number I take
this thing you see I can bend it a
little bit compress it but in order to
make it to change number of holes I have
to do something drastic I have to break
it apart and this stability
of the topological invariants is going
to be important so what does this have
to do with physics well if we go back to
1980 it was a beautiful discovery made
by klaus von klitzy he gave him a Nobel
Prize in 1985 actually for what's called
the quantum Hall effect what he did was
that he took electrons he confined them
into thin layers at very low temperature
and at extremely high magnetic field and
what he found was very amazing he found
that when he measured the electric
conductance in this system he could see
it came in stamps nothing or one unit or
two unit and this unit that he measured
was to an extreme precision sort of an
expected because in this experiment you
cannot control temperature and all other
things very carefully so why could you
get something which is so precise there
were ideas about that but a real
breakthrough came with the discovery of
one of today's low rates David Collins
who could see who could show that these
steps here actually can be explained as
such a topological invariant it's not
exactly as the number of holes in a
bagel or regrets but it's something very
very similar and this also explains why
it is so precise why it's so robust why
you get integer steps and later on 1988
Duncan hall then another of today's low
rates show that you could do the same
without having this very strong magnetic
field and for the continuation of this
field that was very very important now
let's move on to the next concept in
this citation namely topological states
of matter now what is the state of
matter well this is something that you
presumably know from school it's high
temperature you can have a gas lower the
temperature you get liquid lower more
you get a solid
but then you know temperature even more
close to absolute zero there are new
fashion ating phases of matter and the
ones we talked about before these
electrons in a layer that's such the
topological phase or matter that you
find at very low temperature now this is
not the only one holding in 1983 looked
at another kind of system a set of
magnetic atoms in a chain and you could
show that even in this case you had such
an exotic topological phase of matter
and now actually the race is on and you
look for topological phases of matter in
Chains in layers but also in ordinary
three dimensional materials so that was
to fix it was topology for states of
matter now you come to the third phase
transitions was a phase transition well
how do you go from a gas to liquid to a
solid you do it that you know you know
you lower the temperature now what is it
that really happens and these physicists
have started for a long time and it was
a good idea about how these transition
occurs and in particular people believed
that if you had these very thin layers
for instance a thin liquid layer of
helium you would never have such a phase
transition that had been proven
mathematically but yes when people prove
that something cannot happen it might be
that they haven't thought of everything
and the thing that they did not think of
in this case was this thing they did not
think of well not tornadoes but vortices
a tornado is like a big vortex and it's
topologically in the sense you can have
one to lead with you're unlucky you have
two perhaps but you cannot have half a
tornado topological in the same way as
the
number of holes that's a big one here is
a small one this is the artist's renders
rendering some layers of liquid helium
and you see there are small vortices
here here you have a blow-up you can see
the liquid is whirling around here now
at very low temperature these vortices
always comes in pairs actually it's one
wort X going in this direction and
another one going in that direction it's
a pair of vortex and antiwar Tech's they
keep together then you raise the
temperature a little bit then what
happens is that these were tied pairs
now they will sail away and they become
free and that is a case transition a
completely new kind of phase transition
driven by topological effects and this
was also something that you could apply
in many places and the basic paper was
written by coastal isn't ours who found
the phase transition and understood the
vortex mechanism and in a later paper by
Michael Tao eco stirlitz he also worked
out the detailed mathematical theory and
this is something that applies not only
to helium films but in lots of systems
and it's been very important for the
following now that was very shortly what
is about now I will answer the question
that you are going to ask namely what's
it good for
because I know you're going to ask that
but before I ask answer that question
let me tell you something that I feel
deeply about the community feel deeply
about I think all people in physics feel
deeply about and that is that this price
here is for theoretical discoveries it
has combined beautiful mathematical and
profound physics insights and achieved
unexpected results that has been
confirmed by experiments that's what the
price is for it's really beautiful and
it's deep having said that this work has
inspired lots of activity in
perhaps all over the world the national
research scientists are hoping for
practical applications in new
electronics new materials even perhaps
components in the future
bonding computer it has opened this
field it's deadly exciting but the price
today that's for this thank you thank
you ours we may now have one of our new
Nobel laureates with us on a phone line
hello hello professor holding are you
there hello yes I'm here
thank you play with the very nice
summary yeah thank you for being with us
again this is Jonah a non son who called
you about half an hour ago
yeah and I'm now sitting in the session
Hall of the Academy together with
journalists from all over the world and
I'm sure they are eager to ask you some
questions so are you ready to take
questions here yeah who would like to
start too much fun ain't it you've got
the microphone there good morning sir
congratulations thank you there is one
very very basic question but it's easy
to put it the first one what was your
reaction when you have the phone call
half an hour ago well I was as everyone
else's I was very very surprised and
very gratified I know this work is the
work has certainly led to lot been was a
long time ago but it's only now that the
is only now that the a lot of tremendous
new discoveries which are based on this
original work have it and I've extended
it in many ways are now now happening
and it's certainly a subject of of great
great a lot a huge amount of work is
going on on the topological insulators
which which were totally surprising
phenomena which grew out of the this
earlier work that David thought
ahlet's and i and my customers are done
and they have great hopes for this work
- for this these new materials that have
a have a have a big impact in things
like possibility of illogical quantum
computation and lots of such things
thank you more questions yes please lady
over there okay
congratulations a lot of this work was
made in the 70s for instance and I
wonder if we see any applications today
on your work around us
yeah well the work my work with in the
in the late in in the late 80s and at
the time it seemed very abstract and I
wrote and wrote in my paper that the the
model I looked at was an interesting
time model and it was of something which
turned out to be quite like graphene is
today and at the time I felt it was of
scientific interest and mathematical
interest and very fascinating as a
consequence of quantum mechanics that we
hadn't guessed that but I didn't think
you would ever find a practical
realization but if something is actually
possible it'll eventually with material
science any kind of any kind of
unexpected possibilities will eventually
be lead to some concrete realizations
and this and these materials would have
a possibility that that information
either electronic or in other versions
the light can travel in one way around
the system around the edge of the system
and you can have without without the
possibility of being of the information
in the signal being disrupted by by
impurities or bends in the path and so
this this aspect of things has got at
least has a theoretical possibility of
having a great practical implicate in
vacations in in these in subjects like
the dream of building quantum computers
so what what is led to really is that is
taught us that quantum mechanics can
behave far more strangely than we would
have guessed
and we haven't understood all the
possibilities yet and what these
discoveries by myself found earlier by
David Paulus and Mike costless they show
up really that we have a lot a long way
to go to disk discover what's possible
and a lot of these a lot of these things
were things that one would initially
have dreamed were possible and and so
and there's gone on in in in recent
years in the last 10 years this these
ideas have been extended myth it turned
out that a lot of materials but people
had looked at but many years had
actually did have these topological
properties that had just never been
cleaned because people hadn't looked for
them and when they when it was realized
this was possible as the theoretical
discovery that you could extend my work
to a broader class of systems it was the
by by Charlie Kane and gene Mele then
then once and then they realized it
could be extended to two three
dimensional materials and just regular
crystals of things and now people are
just looking and they find and you can
find topological physics in many places
now and it was just something has been
completely overlooked because it
occurred on the surface of materials
rather than in the whole material itself
and and it's really it's I've been very
very surprised by all the recent
unexpected discoveries and extensions of
this and and suddenly people are
realizing that the topological effects
in quantum mechanics are just a
tremendously rich subject and tastic
away a discovery set of discoveries by
small cooper scientists can now
explosion in the whole research field
yeah
questions from the journalists here yes
Mary Hagen we have one more coming up
here yeah hello my name is maria gunther
from dongha's Nieto congratulations to
the price thank you I would like to know
how you could come up with the idea in
the first place of this model well it
was it really was trying to kind of
crystallized tried trying to come up
with a a clear in fact trying to try to
show something somehow something else
was wrong
just to come up with a clear model to
show that you in principle you could you
could get the topological effect I was
looking for but really just to that the
key point was to show that this aspect
that David's Palace had predicted but
found in in in the early 1980s in the
context the very strong magnetic field
this quantum Hall effect would actually
occur in a more general just just when
you had some kind of magnetic materials
that had broken that that had broken
time reversal invariant but didn't
require huge magnetic field and it was
really a it was really a just a toy
model demonstration of something and and
and then it then I realized it was a
very neat model so I basically stumbled
onto this really playing with the
mathematics of some model and I think
similarly David's Alice's discovery he
didn't really realize it was topological
until he just found there was some
number that was stable and later on the
mathematicians told us what the what the
topological what the mathematical
theorems and the topological classes
that was this so we we basically like
like most discoveries you stumble on to
them and you you're you you just have to
realize there's something very
interesting there and when never
realizes the full implications
the things until other people have
started thinking it's true and when
realizes the big picture but most of the
big discoveries are really that way I
think you at least in in theoretical
things you don't you never kind of set
out to discover something new you you
stumble on it and you have the luck to
recognize what you found it is something
very interesting and basically the
problem with was that with all these
things is that you you really need to if
you don't really can't if you can't
visualize what you're trying to do if
not if you don't really know what you
you can't be yeah these things we just
saw which are so surprising it takes a
while to do it but to see it but once
you see it you realize why didn't anyone
else think of that before and really one
can't the barrier the barrier to most of
these things is that you you just don't
you don't realize what's out there and
until someone stumbles over it I think
doesn't be thank you yeah are there more
questions here from journalists yes the
lady over there congratulations on the
prize this is generally from people's
daily and from China my question is
because I read news prepared this
morning and less and less people
especially young people are less and
less interested in physics the first
question is what has inspired you to get
research on the physics and my second
question is what recommendation can give
to the nowadays young young
professionals thank you well I think I
was with my my parents influenced me
with a great interest in science and I
suppose the details of physics like many
things is I was I had the great fortune
to have very inspiring teacher clay
which University you feel under so
understand who is also received later
receive the Nobel Prize and I think
partly the way he explained his on his
unorthodox ideas then and inspired me
tremendously and now I think actually
that this whole topological quantum
physics has actually become an
inspiration for a lot of a generation of
young of young physicists in the in
recent years in at least in condensed
matter physics and also it's now
reaching a bit into particle physics or
highly for people in in in in high
energy physics have got interested
this whole possibilities of topological
physics have actually been tremendously
inspiring to too many young people
working in physics these days and you
see the coffee cup turning into the
donut and back again as a meme in in all
kinds of talks yeah so let's hope that
I'm sure that you will be able to convey
your enthusiasm to students and young
scientists when you come here in
December so that was the last question
thank you very much professor Holden for
being with us at this press conference
and see you in December thank you very
much beautiful bye bye bye are there any
questions to the panel hans has promised
to take maybe one or two questions
before he has his lunch and Vince and I
are also available I know that some of
you are eager to move on cuz you AR have
individual interviews and broadcast and
so on if there aren't any further
questions then I think we'll close this
part of the press conference and we'll
proceed with individual interviews with
Nobel Committee members for those of you
held requesting such interviews thank
you very much very interestin welcome
back tomorrow for the chemistry prize
thank you
you
professor to Shawn Johnson you're a
member of the Nobel Committee for
physics and you just presented an
about-face this year it is about exotic
matter in the quantum world so my first
question would be exotic is not a
precise scientific term exotic is
something that expresses our wonder I'll
wander in front of something that is
very unusual very hard to understand and
I think also that has to be seen
historically what is exciting exciting
for us now might not be so exotic in 20
or 30 years I guess you know electricity
was very exotic when it first came
around it's not so exotic any longer but
today the basis of matter I guess we
come to that that is at the basis of
this year's price is really exotic world
so where is this quantum oil well the
quantum world is in a sense all around
us but quantum effects are not always
very obvious to see but when you cool
down materials to very low temperature
then in many cases quantum effects
becomes very much more visible more
apparent then I have another exotic
question perhaps we have this bagel and
you had also a cinnamon roll what do
they do in this event price talks well
they are actually there to illustrate
something and to illustrate that is not
sufficient to just show the bagel but I
anticipated these questions I brought
also the bond you see when you're both
the bond and you have the bagel then you
can see that the difference is that the
bagel has a
and the bond doesn't and the important
be the whole is that all the things like
taste or shape or deformation can change
continuously but the number of holes
which something that we call the
topological invariant it can only change
like integers 1 2 3 0 this is 0 holes
this is one hole I challenge you to
imagine what is a hospital what would be
to have horrible you cannot have alcohol
you need 0 1 2 and these this fact that
you have integers that are of
topological nature that's intimately
connected to the effects and the
description of these faces that is at
the basis of the process mathematics
there has a few role in this about price
of the year what worked for what was the
role of the ecology well the role of
topology is there are many roads or
topology actually one role of topology
is that these so called topological
invariants I took the example the number
of holes actually directly gets into the
mathematical description of these phases
now it is takes advanced mathematics to
write the formula that counts the number
of holes in a donut or calculates that
there is here a hole in a cinnamon bomb
that's advanced mathematics but I
understand the concept that this is one
hole that is 0 whole deck anyone can
understand and that is actually the
important thing for for the basic result
were the discoverers of this year's
Lawrence
it was sealed ethical discoveries that
we should remember and it also
illustrates in a very nice way the
interplay between physics and
mathematics which we're theoretical
physics is in the actual ethic at at the
crossroad because the quantum Hall
effect which was the starting point for
David Paulus understanding of it as a
topological effect there was an
experiment that was already done and he
explained the experiment using these
topological invariants while in another
case the case of Duncan Holden who
predicted certain properties of the
Omaha the topological states actually
change of magnetic atoms and also
something similar to the quantum Hall
effect I get out the magnetic field that
was theoretical discoveries that
predicted effects that was later seen in
experiment in one case actually 25 years
later and it took much more advanced
experimental techniques to do it very
surprising experiment so they expected
it will come
in many cases when you have a
theoretical possibility since there is
so much variety in experiments you can
do in materials in experimental setups
in many many cases you come up with the
case where it's actually realized you
cannot say for sure but experiments
experience shows that that happens very
often so there's of course very exciting
possible applications of this exotic
topological matter in the future I can
just tell you what people are dreaming
about but also working very hard in the
labs to do and that is to get new
materials which has you know interesting
properties of conducting electricity but
also conducting other things like what
is called spin and the beam is that this
can be used for carry information it's
also has quantum mechanical properties
something that is called entanglement
that makes people hope that perhaps you
can use these things to code quantum
information in an efficient way so who
knows you know there might be a future
quantum computer where topological
effects are important if you don't know
but I certainly know people are
speculating about it can you tell us a
little about the laureates the prizes
awarded half to David powers and half to
Duncan Haldane and Michael customers can
you explain this yeah there are two
parts in the in the citation topological
phases and topological phase transitions
that is how you go in between them and
David Thewlis is given
important contributions to both organ -
topological phase transitions together
with David powerless and - topological
phases he did this important work in
their later whole gain did also very
important work
so David Thewlis has a share in both
these parts of the citation that's what
he gets
you